[Musik]
ich mach youtube seit mittlerweile mehr
als zehn jahren
und
wir sind glaube ich noch nie
vor einem video die worte weggeblieben
und ich wusste nicht was ich sagen soll
[Musik]
ich stehe seit einer halben stunde in
diesem feld erstellungs- menü in
minecraft
wenn meine lieben freunde ihr seht ja
bereits einen titel eingeblendet es geht
los
aber ich heute recht herzlich willkommen
heißen zur zweiten staffel minecraft mit
luca
[Musik]
bevor ich hier noch länger in diesem
menü rummler ganz kurze info an alle wir
haben natürlich selbstverständlich
keinen zieht am start und ich werde die
welt jetzt einfach direkt erstellen
experimentelle einstellung finden wir
nicht
meine lieben freunde ich darf euch heute
recht herzlich willkommen heißen zur
ersten folge des neuen projekts
minecraft mit luca
2.0
ich bin in dem wald
es war gut
besser als in so einem komischen
[Musik]
das nicht dass irgendwas im staffel 1
direkt über all unserem
bei der liebe freunde wir dürfen keine
zeit verlieren ihr seht schon hier sind
ein paar sachen anders der eine oder
andere mannschaften luca fällen wird
schnell kein
hübscher wird sie wahrscheinlich auch
fragen luca wissen dass sie viel
komisches durch das du hier gerade
durchläuft erneuern will sich
wahrscheinlich auf fragen mensch luca
irgendwie
hast du direkt buchen der hand
[Musik]
das war der schnellste tod
dienst glaube ich in minecraft gab unser
buch ist jetzt natürlich weg das wissen
wir ganz kurz noch mal wiederholen ich
weiß jetzt nicht wo die ich dieses tier
krokodil ich weiß ist zwar da haben wir
es so das wörterbuch von tieren einmal
wieder zurück am stand ich auf einmal
ganz schnell wieder raus aus dem sumpf
ähnlichen dingen hier vorne das krokodil
schild hier vor das hat uns einfach
direkt angegriffen festgehalten ich
konnte nicht weg ich konnte das ding
auch nicht boxen oder irgendwas was ich
hab hier noch mehr krokodile ebenso sind
allerdings ist dieses bio wirklich nicht
so das wahre
dieses komische ding was da hinten sich
aufgebaut hat schauen wir uns auch in
der heutigen folge nicht an die sache
ist allerdings fraglich wahrscheinlichen
luca mensch meint staffel 2 was ist
jetzt alles anders das werde ich euch
jetzt erstmal ganz groß verraten denn
wir befinden uns hier in der minecraft
version 1.17 punkt 1 eine alte minecraft
ist unglaublich 1 punkt
16.5 oder so also wir spielen hier
wirklich das neueste vom neuesten und
ihr seht auch gerade schon luca der ist
hier direkt fix unterwegs ja ich will
mir direkt eine werkbank und eine axt
denn dann kann ich euch direkt zeigen
was das nächste was die nächste
neuigkeit hier ist den baum hat sich als
einfach mal ein bisschen zu groß ist
kann ich euch das anhand dieses baumes
komische geräusche er ich kann euch das
anhand dieses baumes zeigen denn ich
muss jetzt nur noch den untersten blog
abfälle und dann
geht der ganze baum direkt weg der ein
oder andere wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
sagen mensch luca das ist cheating
blabla nähe ist es nicht soll ich mal
meine ab sondern die hatten die hälfte
ihrer lebensdauer jetzt gerade quasi
verloren nur dadurch weil ich einen baum
gefällt habe es ist einfach noch
schneller und das ist das geile ich
lasse das ding glaube ich nicht dass das
nicht stehen wir laufen direkt bei den
wohin und schauen ob gegen eine höhle
haben für kohle und silber
doch
auch silber silber wir bewegen uns doch
erstmal ganz schnell weg von diesem
komischen sumpf nach vorne und keine
sorge das teil dahin das werden wir
demnächst oder noch mal irgendwann
uns genau anschauen ich muss mich
allerdings jetzt wirklich erstmals
sputen denn ich möchte heute und das ist
auch das ziel für die erste episode
minecraft mit luca meine lieben freunde
ich möchte heute in ersten tag und die
erste nacht erfolgreich überleben
deswegen hier
ist das habe
aha
tschüss ja meine lieben freunde das ziel
für die heutige episode ist es diese
schon fast beim mittag angekommen wie
ich möchte natürlich überleben ich
glaube das ist generell das ziel in
minecraft mit lukas kummer der braut
sich dazu noch die wirklich auch das ist
sehr sehr geil das perfekt jetzt eben
aber direkt die ganze sache hier am
start die aktie ist jetzt natürlich
schon halb kaputt aber egal das wirklich
sehr gerne die modifikation treat
schoppa heißt die falls sich gern haben
möchte das geht einfach deutlich
schneller also das ist auf jeden fall
neue wir haben die neue version 1.17
ergebnis geisteskranke neue höhlen es
doch eine menge neuer andere sachen was
das alles genau jetzt könnt ihr mir
gerne und medien kommentare schreiben
ich weiß nicht genau was alles hinzu
gekommen ist wir haben
wir sind glaube ich auch in der version
1.4 mit dazu gekommen die sind aber
ängstlich die laufen von mir weg
vielleicht kann man die indizien
könnt ihr gerne in die kommentare
schreiben wir müssen uns allerdings erst
mal nebenbei so ein bisschen um steine
könnten sich allerdings schon was
deswegen kann ich mal direkt weiter
quatschen was noch so neu ist das
texture pack einer lieben freundin wir
haben direkt kohl okay das ist sehr wild
neue sixpack ihr seht schon wir haben
hier so übergänge vom rasen so dem stein
zum beispiel wir haben neue kohle
texturen wir haben generell ein paar
sachen die ein bisschen anders aussehen
das texture pack heißt stay true texture
pack das geil an diesen texture pack ist
das alles also das hier ist alles gleich
geblieben und das ist halt dass
ich habe hier die uridee abgebaut
so dass keiner den text ist dass die
meisten sachen wirklich gleich aussehen
und man so ein bisschen wie der name
schon sagt stay true bleibt also man
bleibt den normalen dingen
war
treu
ich weiß auch nicht sogar mega ihm
gesprochen deswegen weil ich das texture
pack an skype was wir auch noch an
neuigkeiten haben ist zum beispiel neues
intro das habt ihr heute allerdings
nicht gesehen sondern dass sie erst in
der nächsten episode minecraft ducati
allerdings direkt morgen online gehen
wird also stellt euch ab jetzt sind
heime oder ein kalendereintrag
immer 18 uhr nicht ganz daily ab und zu
machen wir mal einen tag pause dann lade
ich dann etwas anderes weil wie gesagt
ich wollte mich noch nicht auf youtube
so einschränken sondern ich will mal das
hochland worauf ich bock haben wir haben
vorne eine höhle können uns allerdings
direkt mal eben vier fackel machen ich
möchte mich nur gucken ob wir hier
direkt vielleicht reisen finden irgendwo
das wäre sehr sehr geil denn dann
könnten wir uns direkt da essen wir
haben direkt reisen wir können uns dann
direkt eine schere machen und
hoffentlich wenn wir schafe finden einen
bet kräften so dass du die erste nacht
vielleicht sogar direkt überspringen
können so dass wir nicht sterben im
heutigen
ich wurde schon vom krokodil getötet ist
aber egal wir haben genug eisen für eine
spitzhacke tatsächlich und sogar autor
für eine schere deswegen mal ganz kurz
sie wieder in sicherheit und die
werkbank hinstellen daraus können wir
uns einmal ganz fix ebenen ofen machen
wir sehen schon die sonne geht
vielleicht schon unter deswegen müssen
wir uns wirklich ein bisschen sputen das
intro bereits vorhin gesagt erfahrt ihr
sie seht ihr dann zum ersten mal im
nächsten video morgen 18 uhr also da
müsst ihr auf jeden fall einschalten was
ihr da auch noch sehen werdet ist
vielleicht eine minimap
denn meine lieben freunde ich habe hier
wie die
96 mini mehr pro tag geladen die habe
ich allerdings gerade ausgeschaltet das
ist eine minimap die ihr dann ich hier
oben eingeblendet und die ist quasi so
ein bisschen zur hilfe da das wir sehen
wo wir uns befinden weil wir uns ja in
den letzten projekt das ein oder andere
mal leider verlaufen haben ich weiß
allerdings nicht ob das vielleicht zu
sehen ist wo es mal reisen
reisen sieht jetzt so aus
sie aus den pilz oder
wie irgendwie so ein
hähnchenbrustfilet oder so ist das eis
noch okay das sind ganz normale
eisenbahn wir haben auch schon den
fortschritt metall nur mit hallo
metallurgie
erzählt naja
[Musik]
ich kann nicht oft genug sagen
die wunderschönen eigenschaft ist na ja
wir nehmen uns jetzt erstmal das eisen
raus und trafen uns als allererstes eine
schere und begeben uns auf die suche
nach scharfen vielleicht haben ja hier
vor dem wald direkt schafe um allerdings
jetzt mal beim thema zu bleiben ihr
dürft entscheiden ob ich mir die minimap
oh mein gott das ist nicht wahr
das kannst du dir wirklich nicht
ausdenken wir haben direkt drei schafe
so dass wir wirklich safe safe fassen
dieser kabarettist verfolgte auch
überall hin dass wir uns direkt im bett
machen kann er das ist doch unfassbar
also ich nehme meine sachen jetzt mal
weg weil ich fand dass da vorne ich ganz
schön in dieser kleinen lichtung
deswegen direkt hier die den lasse ich
erst mal ganz gut stehen dann nicht
nehmen das eisen hier raus und mache mir
jetzt auch direkt sagt zack meine neue
spitzhacke so dass ich dann auch geile
sachen abbauen kann und ich werde mir
auch direkten schwert machen
hab ich jetzt vielleicht dom geplant
dass ich mir nicht ein
schweinestall spitzhacke gemacht habe
und reisen schwert aber naja so sind wir
jetzt ich nehme doch mal ganz kurz sie
die axt baut das hier eben ab und dann
bauen wir den ofen ab und dann können
wir uns mal direkt zur lichtung der
vorne bewegen die sonne da hinten geht
schon montag ich möchte direkt
schlafengehen ich will nicht mit
irgendwelchen monstern heute
aneinandergeraten weil der auch hier bin
ich noch gar nicht darauf eingegangen
das wörterbuch von tieren haben und wenn
ich da einfach mal richtig drauf da seht
ihr schon wir haben ganz viele neue
tiere insgesamt war liebe freunde mehr
als 55 neue tiere monster sachen wie
spector sachen wie
stadtrat paul komische neue spinnen wir
haben einen fetten hey
wir haben das klingt wir haben ganz ganz
viele sachen war das jetzt überhaupt
eine rabe davor hin
gorilla war es wahrscheinlich nicht das
ist auf jeden fall das wörterbuch von
tieren an bord das geil aus
[Musik]
und die füchse und hier geht die sonne
unter zwischen den bäumen ich freue mich
meine lieben freunde ich freue mich auf
diese neue staffel minecraft mit luca
2.0 und ich glaube ich glaube niemand
hat damit gerechnet dass ich in der
ersten episode was ist das
was ist das
[Musik]
ich glaube niemand hat damit gerechnet
dass wir in der heutigen episode in der
ersten episode minecraft mit luca direkt
ein bett haben werden deswegen war ganz
fix eben hier die sachen nehmen und
sagen dann haben wir hier das bett
können uns das bett hier hinsetzen und
können direkt schlafen gehen
[Musik]
platz geschafft
wir haben die erste nacht überlebt
und ich bin nicht mehr auf alle punkte
eingegangen die ich euch sagen wollte
von daher können wir jetzt die letzten
minuten nochmal ganz groß nutzen um ein
bisschen holz zu fällen weil du lieben
freunde holz ist immer wichtig und wir
müssen wir gleich noch ein bisschen
steiner abbauen die sache ist allerdings
meine lieben freunde ich möchte jetzt
beginnen zum ende des heutigen videos
zum ende des ersten teils minecraft die
buga 2015 zu komisch an wieder videos
auf ziemlich harte wochen pause gemacht
zum ende des videos kann ich euch noch
mal ganz kurz die sachen sagen jetzt
wirklich neu sind die spiele in der
neuen version minecraft 1.17
dementsprechend haben wir eine menge
neuer sachen hier am start wir haben
einige modifikationen auch direkt
installiert wie beispielsweise diese tri
top modifikation wo wir wollen wir
direkt abfällen können ich habe
allerdings auch eine modifikation
reingepackt namens beim scotland ist
wieder sehr scheiß habe bei uns ablehnte
wäre viele haben hier
in beirut plenty geht es darum dass wir
eine menge neue biome haben die werden
wir mit der dauer des projekts auf jeden
fall noch weiter entdecken also bleibt
auf jeden fall dran abonniert main kanal
falls ihr die nächsten tag nicht
verpassen wollte und wir haben natürlich
die alex mops
modifikation installiert wodurch wird
diese ganzen neuen mops ihr haben bzw
wir haben ja erst nur die spiegel
entdeckt und den rahmen es gibt noch 55
anderem ops deswegen werden wir auch die
nächsten episoden so ein bisschen
entdecken unsere achse soeben kaputt
gegangen wir haben da
und 90 mit einem biss kopf
ja
dann bei der lieben freunde natürlich
morgen traten dann was das neue intro
ist hunger ich muss mich direkt in der
nächsten folge auch immer zu essen
kümmern in der nächsten folge wertete er
dann erfahren was das neue intro ist da
freue ich mich auch schon drauf ist es
gekürzt und ein bisschen anders als das
erst dabei alles ist anders wir haben
auch neue hintergrundmusik wir haben
ganz ganz viele sachen von daher wenn du
die mit freunde würde ich an der stelle
der heutigen episode und damit auch die
erste episode
der schwabe steht auf meiner werkbank
danke ich werde an der stelle die
heutige episode und damit auch die erste
episode der neuen staffel minecraft mit
luca beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
das kann einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da abonniert
selbstverstänlich main kanal wenn ihr
die neuen episoden nicht verpassen
wollte und legt auf die glocke wenn ihr
eine benachrichtigung bekommen wollte
sobald ich ein neues video hochladen und
jetzt könnt ihr bitte auch noch gerne
und in die kommentare schreiben erstens
wenn ihr wollt dass die minimap
aktiviert wird ich kann es euch einmal
ganz kurz zeigen so wird es aussehen
wenn die minimap aktiviert wäre
der ball fliegt durch bedarf haben wir
es und dann können wir uns ein bisschen
umgucken ich kann mir dort noch weg
punkte markieren ich kann auch die
koordinaten einstellen und sagen wo sich
welches monster gerade befindet das will
ich aber alles nicht das habe ich alles
schon freuen dann ausgestellt in der
anderen test welt von mir deswegen die
wird wirklich nur so da oben am start
sein um so ein bisschen zu gucken wo bin
ich gerade wo kann ich hinlaufen ich
kann dann auch ran zoomen damit sie noch
ein bisschen größer zeigt ein bisschen
mehr an bin ich allerdings gar nicht ich
mache jetzt erst mal aus und ihr dürft
entscheiden ob die an sein soll oder
nicht also schreibt eine 1 und in die
kommentare wenn die minimap an sein soll
in der nächsten episode 2 und in die
kommentare wenn die minimap generell
nicht am start sein soll oder vielleicht
eher nur ein paar des speziellen
situationen schreibt uns in die
kommentare schreibt mir zudem bitte auch
gerne in die kommentare welches monster
welches geräusch machen soll wir haben
heute keinen käufer gesehen wir haben
auch kein zombie gesehen wir haben keine
spinnen gesehen haben nur eins bleibt
mit einem kürbis kopf gesehen und
gedacht entscheiden welches monster
welches geräusch machen soll also
schreibt mit die beiden sachen unten die
kommentare minimap an oder aus eins oder
zwei und in die kommentare und welche
geräusche welche sätze welches monster
sagen soll
was dann genau der fall sein wird
erfahrt ihr dann in der nächsten episode
morgen um 18 uhr stündlich einschalten
meine lieben freunde und ab da
jetzt weiter
ich habe mich ganz doll lieb und ich
freue mich auf eine richtig geile zeit
bekommen gerade listen die tränen
aber egal
[Musik]